[Music]
this episode is brought to you by our
patrons over at patreon.com journeyto
micro if you'd like to join our
community of patreon supporters you can
sign up for just $2 a month with that
you'll not only be supporting these
videos but you'll also get access to our
Patron only Discord and you'll get a
monthly hourlong video of some of our
uncut footage if you join our $8 tier
you will still get access to the Discord
and monthly uncut videos but you'll also
get weekly highres wallpapers and your
name in the list of supporters that we
show at the end of every episode also
you'll get our microcosmos Field Guide
and our coloring book absolutely free so
check out our patreon today over at
[Music]
back on the screen than a living
organism things may seem quiet and calm
but along its body the killer wears its
victims it would be understandable
though if you missed that part those
victims have been so engulfed from
within by their enemy that they look
more like unusual leaves or bits of
debris not an animal swimming around the
microcosmos and certainly not a rifer
caught in the strands of a predacious
[Music]
fungus if you've been following Journey
to the microcosmos for some time this
might sound like a familiar story a few
years ago we featured a horror story of
sorts starring a fungus that that spins
a web to trap worms so consider this a
proper slasher movie sequel you don't
need to have seen the original to
understand what's happening but we do
hope that when you're done watching
riers suffer their ultimate ends under
strange circumstances you might want to
go back and watch some nematodes suffer
a similar
fate sequels are of course tricky things
and you run the challenge of treading a
lot of the same ground of course we will
have plenty of violence and death but
fortunately this rifer packed sequel
brings something else to the table that
nematodes didn't have sex but first to
the violence and
death there are at least 60 species of
funi that we know of that attack rapers
much of what we know about these species
comes from SCI scientists using rapers
as bait they take a sample of rotifers
and then they add a bit of soil to see
if the fungus is in there and then they
watch sounds a little dark when we
phrase it that way but of course here we
are watching this zuop fagus fungus that
was growing inside of a humidity chamber
as it eats away at a Rota
fer from a distance the fungus seems so
dull and uninteresting it's not even
moving except of course that it is
inside the fungus there's a flurry of
activity as nutrients and molecules
stream through the cytoplasm and across
the vast expanses of this predator's
body this rotifer has been caught by a
fungus flopping from side to side while
the fungus seems to do nothing an animal
that can swim up against an organism
that can't move that shouldn't be a
fight but the Raper is stuck it is
caught on adhesive pegs that line the
fungus making it impossible for the
rifer to escape and then there are the
hyy the threads of the fungus that grow
and lie in
weight soon the rifer will be more like
this immobilized and ins snared in ayst
the fungus's digestive hyy are embedded
within the roer's body now and eating it
from within it takes only about a day
for a fungus to trap and consume its
prey like this but it is still not
done within another day the rifer will
essentially be filled with hyy some even
beginning to poke back through the body
of its prey the fungus has been feeding
and feeding but still it is not
done within another day the highi will
produce spores planting the seed for the
fungi's future all at the expense of
that
[Music]
rooper in 1954 one scientist documenting
the various fungal attacks on rotifers
within his lab noticed that they seem to
have an unusual Preference they seemed
to only Target roers that have AA which
is like a shell the soft-bodied rotifers
within their samples seemed to be able
to wander all around the fungi with no
problem and that sounds like wrong right
shells are protective they keep you safe
from things that are trying to eat you
but the shells are not a deterrent to
the fungi quite the opposite in fact the
fungi seem to use the shell as a place
to hook their hyy into using the roer's
shield instead as a tool for Invasion
these fungi also go after another type
of rifer the deloid rer
a class of rotifers that is fairly large
encompassing hundreds of species these
rotifers are known for one very specific
thing no one has ever observed them
having sex it's not like they're shy or
anything they don't know we're watching
they just don't seem to do it maybe
there's been some very recent work
sifting through their genomes that
suggest that maybe sexual reproduction
has showed up in their past but that's a
discussion for another day for now the
fact remains that no one has seen deloid
Rivers actually engaging in sexual
reproduction and not for a lack of
looking even more curiously no one has
ever seen what is confirmed to be a male
deloid rer there are as far as we know
only female deloid rotifers they
reproduced through parthenogenesis able
to make their own egg that will hatch
into a daughter that only has her
mother's jeans scientists have wondered
about this process for some time and how
deloid rapers have been able to survive
for millions and millions of years
without the advantages that sexual
reproduction confers on a species like
the ability to introduce variation that
could help them adapt to the world
around them a world that includes
predatory fungi but that's also LED
scientists to wonder if perhaps these
fungi are the reason why deloid rers are
so singularly reliant on asexual
reproduction because asexual
reproduction has at least one clear
advantage on sexual reproduction it is
faster you don't have to spend time
finding a mate or expend energy with all
the various processes involved with
cording and copulating that nature has
engineered that's potentially useful to
an animal that finds itself on the run
from a fungus and deloid Ropers have
another secret weapon they are extremely
Hardy able to turn into a dormant ton
that can survive extreme conditions and
that means they could survive something
like a strong wind which could blow them
away from their predators and drop them
off in a new home that is hopefully a
little less fungal so this ability to
outrun their predators and to quickly
reproduce when they reach a new less
threatening environment that's a
potentially powerful combination one
that could serve to explain why deloid
riers focus on asexual reproduction at
the expense of everything else but it is
for now still just one idea for Why
deloid riers Live the way they do the
reality is probably even more complex
than what we know now filled with even
more twists than the fungus that hunt
this rifer and more sequels than we will
probably ever
know
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us the people on the
screen right now that's right they are
our $8 patreon patrons so thank you so
much to everybody who's ever signed up
to be a patron of Journey to the
microcosmos especially the people who
are currently signed up right now you
can check it out at
patreon.com journey to micro and you can
be one of the people who are the reason
why this thing can exist if you want to
see more from our master of microscopes
James Weiss check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's probably a subscribe
button somewhere nearby and if you want
to hit the little notification Bell you
can but please do it softly we're trying
to stay chill around
[Music]
here